hi I'm John a lot of people here call me
sloppy because respawn has an awful lot
of John's I'm a lead engineer on
titanfall 2 and I wanted to talk about
servers today so a lot of people have
asked us what are you doing for your
servers on titanfall 2 and that's a
great question so just to rewind on
titanfall one we ran a hundred percent
of our servers on Microsoft's Azure
cloud and we learned a lot doing it and
our big takeaway was that it worked
really well and so we're going to keep
doing that so we're still on Microsoft
Azure we're also on Google's cloud and
we're on Amazon's Cloud and on top of
all of that we're also going to be
running what's called bare metal boxes
which are just servers in racks and data
centers all over the world that we rent
like a month at a time so we've been
working with this company called
multipla and they've been in the server
hosting business for a really long time
so their expertise has been really
useful for us to learn about all these
different ways of running servers and so
we've been working with them to build a
system so that we can use both bare
metal and multiple clouds together and
you'll see more of that during tech
tests and obviously during launch as we
work with multiplayer to learn all these
things and get ready for tech tests this
is where we really have a bunch of
questions about like how is each one
going to perform when we're allocating
you know hundreds of thousands of player
slots and so that for the tech test this
is going to be our big chance to really
make sure that all our assumptions are
good and we learn enough so that launch
is great and so we really need you to
come and bang on on servers and play the
game and do your worst at it we spent a
really long time making sure this stuff
is going to scale and work well but
we'll find out if that's true so please
come and destroy all of our hard work
play the tech test take our servers down
let us learn from it and get ready for
launch we really would appreciate it and
we're really looking forward to getting
the game in your hands